Hi.
Uh,
this is John Shinnecock.
Plus again,
I'm here to give a lecture that I gave one evening,
uh,
that we couldn't record.
So I'm going to try and reproduce the lecture as faithfully as I can.
And I think,
uh,
it's a historical lecture.
I hope you'll find it interesting.
It's about the history of the mortgage market,
and I call it a personal history because by some accident I participated at many
of the key points and the recent history of the mortgage market.
So I started off in eight,
1989.
I was professor here at Yale.
I was a mathematical economist.
I thought of myself as,
uh,
using mathematics to study economics and staying really pretty much as far from
the real world as I could.
But for some reason I decided that I wanted to see what was going on on Wall
Street.
The most interesting mathematical modeling of that day was being done on Wall
Street and mathematical modeling and finance.
That is an economics.
And so I decided why not go see it?
And so I visited a bunch of investment banks,
a number of my friends,
including one from Yale,
had had worked at Goldman Sachs.
So that was the natural thing to do.
But I had a little cousin who had just been hired,
uh,
recently,
a little bit before that at a kidder Peabody,
which was sort of the number seventh,
uh,
Investment Bank of the time in terms of size.
And he introduced me to the fellow Ed Sarillo who ran fixed income at the time.
And they persuaded me that would be much more interesting to go to kidder
Peabody and to talk to people like Ed Thrill,
then go to Goldman Sachs and be one of a hundred visiting professors.
So I decided that from was a little bit smaller,
but I'd see more of it and why not do something a little bit different.
So they'd never had an academic visitor.
I think,
like me spend a year there before.
So I went in 1989,
1990.
And uh,
while I was there,
I talked a lot to Zarrillo until the traders and to a bunch of other people.
And at the end of the,
my sabbatical,
ed Sorello came to me and he said,
you know,
I've come to realize that our fixed income research department isn't for a
mathematical,
why don't you hire a research department for me and I'll help you along.
But you find the people,
you know,
the subject,
uh,
you can judge,
you know,
your business is judging people doing research.
Why don't you hire me a research department.
So I hired him,
a research department,
which ultimately grew to 75 people.
And,
uh,
I returned to Yale and after I got back to Yale,
he called me up and he said,
you know,
now that you've hired the research department,
you have heads of all these different groups.
Why don't you run the research department and you can do it from Yale and,
uh,
as a consultant.
And so I became the head of fixed income research at kidder Peabody,
uh,
from Yale.
And I,
uh,
it was quite an experience I hadn't realized when I accepted the job,
just to how many complications would arise,
how many people would get job offers from other places and want to leave.
And how many models wouldn't work and then there'd have to be a wild scramble to
fix it.
But anyway,
that placed me at an investment bank,
a one of the what?
That would become one of the key players in the mortgage market now in the
mortgage market will,
who are the players,
whether the homeowners you all know about,
they're the banks who are giving mortgage loans.
But then there are a number of other players that are invisible to much of the
public,
which really dominate the market.
They're the government agencies,
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac,
which you'll hear a lot about their,
the investment banks,
like kidder Peabody and Goldman Sachs and a bunch of others.
They're the hedge funds and there are other investors and this group of people
creates a gigantic hierarchy,
an invisible market that's on the same size,
the same scale as the stock market.
So I think in that time,
1989,
1990,
if you'd asked anyone in America practically what's an important financial
market,
they would have said to stock market.
What's another important financial market?
Corporate bond market.
What's another one?
Well,
um,
foreign exchange market,
what's another one?
Options market.
I don't think anyone would have said the mortgage market or at least they
wouldn't have put said it very early on in the,
in the,
in their list of important,
uh,
financial markets.
But in fact,
as I'm going to try and tell you during this class,
the mortgage market is on the scene,
not only on the same scale as the stock market,
but actually quite a bit more complicated than the stock market,
more mathematical than the stock market.
And in some ways more interesting than the stock market.
And as we'll see at the end of the course,
it was the mortgage market that led to the greatest crisis we've had since the
depression and in fact caused several similar crisis before that.
So,
uh,
mortgages appear at the bottom.
You have homeowners living in their houses who need to borrow the money to buy
the house before they can live in the house.
They have to get the money to buy the house.
So they borrow the money by taking out a mortgage and it's a bank or a thrift or
somebody like that who lends them the money.
That's the first step.
So a mortgage is just a promise to pay the loan back over a long period of time
using your house as collateral.
Uh,
an important part of mortgages is that you have an option to prepay the
mortgage.
I mean,
what if you move the mortgages to say a 30 year promise and after three years
you might want to move.
So if you're gone from the house,
the house can no longer serve as collateral because you don't live in it
anymore.
So there has to be some way of getting out of the mortgage.
And so there's an option to prepay it.
Now in the United States,
that option can be used even if you stay in the house.
And it turns out to be one of the more problematic,
uh,
aspects of valuing mortgages and one of the most interesting aspects of my
failure with mortgages.
But we'll come to that later.
So this idea of a mortgage,
uh,
those three ideas were already known to the Babylonians more than 3000 years
ago.
So the mortgage is not a recent invention.
It wasn't invented,
uh,
you know,
after the industrial revolution,
it was invented more than 3000 years ago,
uh,
near the Middle East.
So,
uh,
it stayed pretty much the same for most of those 3000 years until the 1930s when
the amortizing mortgage was invented.
So what happened in the 1930s,
that was the time of the Great Depression and farmers had lots of mortgages and
they would owe $7 a year,
say,
is their interest payment.
And at the end of the 10 or 15 years,
they'd have to pay $107.
That is,
they make their interest payment and they pay back the balance,
what's called now a balloon payment.
That's how a typical bond works.
Well,
of course,
when things got really bad,
a lot of them defaulted and naturally they chose to default just before the
hundred $7 payment.
So seeing that,
uh,
mortgage lenders decided that it would be much safer to make a flat mortgage
loan where the payment was say $8 a year for all of 30 years.
Now you pay a little bit more each year for 29 years,
but then you continue to pay the eight,
the 30th year.
But you see,
if you add up all the extra payments and you realize that there's discounting
the hundred seven way off in the end isn't really that much money it's looked at
from the beginning.
And so by paying eight every year,
you can get the same,
uh,
present discounted value of paying seven 29 years in 107 the 30th year.
So that's called the amortizing mortgage.
It makes the lender much safer because after a bunch of years have gone by,
uh,
the house presumably has gone up in value,
or even if it hasn't gone up in value,
the remaining payments are much less because so many have been made.
The,
the,
the balance has been amortized.
And so actually to get out of your mortgage,
you,
you need to pay less than a hundred dollars back.
So this amortizing mortgage is something we're going to study mathematically in
the next lecture.
But now I just mentioned that was one of the big innovations which made the
mortgage market much safer than it had been before.
Well,
so things continued pretty much the same from the 1930s all the way till the
1970s when we had securitization.
Like many of the great financial innovations and in history,
this one was created by the government.
So a Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac were government agencies and they had,
they were given the job,
they were created by the government.
Uh,
they then became eventually separate from the government,
but they had the,
they were given the task,
they were created for the purpose of making mortgage pass throughs.
So we're in the 1970s.
So mortgage pass throughs are the second tier of this hierarchy.
So the banks who had lent the mortgage,
remember when you take out a mortgage as a homeowner,
you're selling your promise,
you're getting the money by selling your promise to pay back later.
So those promises are collected by the banks.
And instead of just sitting on the,
the banks now with Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac could sell their promises,
uh,
to Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac and Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac would put them
together in gigantic pools called pass through pools.
Why were they called pass throughs?
Because the mortgage payments the homeowner's made would go to the banks and the
banks would just pass them on to the pools and then the pools would collect the
money and pass that money on to the shareholders.
So the ultimate lenders to the homeowners are the people who buy shares in the
fanny and Freddy pools.
So the banks appear to the homeowner to be lending the money,
but actually they're not lending it at all.
They're the middleman.
And so they collect the money from the homeowner and they send it on to the
actual lender who's the shareholder in the pool.
And the banks are also there.
The service are really,
they're getting paid a fee for collecting the money and,
and writing threatening letters.
If the home owner stops paying.
And as we'll see later throwing the homeowner out of his house if the homeowner
doesn't pay.
So Fanny and Freddy,
uh,
played an extraordinarily important role in the mortgage market.
First of all,
not any mortgage could be sold into these pools.
They had to meet strict criterions.
You had to have a good credit rating,
you had to have a job,
you had to have all sorts of,
uh,
sorry about this.
I'm going to have to shut off my cell phone.
Um,
okay.
So you and the,
uh,
the loan to value of the mortgage had to be that is that the house is worth a
hundred.
The loan could only be 80% of it.
Um,
uh,
you had to have a record of the job you had a and so on.
So this was a very,
um,
very standardized and very high performing loans.
So you could contrast this,
say to the world that you might've seen in the movie.
It's a wonderful life.
So in the movie,
it's a wonderful life.
You remember Jimmy Stewart runs a thrift and he makes mortgage loans and people
come to him and they say we want alone.
And He,
you know,
one guy comes through and says he wants a loan.
Uh,
Jimmy Stewart says,
well,
do you have,
do you have any collateral?
No,
I haven't built a house yet.
I'm trying to build the house.
Do you have,
do you have a record of employment?
No,
I've just moved here.
I don't have,
you know,
I even have a job yet.
Um,
uh,
do you have someone who can vouch for,
you know,
um,
do you have a credit rating?
No,
there is no such thing as credit rating.
So then Jimmy Stewart looks into his eyes and realizes this is a good honest
person and gives them alone.
Well,
that doesn't happen in the Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac pools.
They're very standardized criteria and uh,
very that that Guy Marta on who got the loan from Jimmy Stewart would never have
gotten a conforming Fannie and Freddie or Freddie loan in the 1980s or nineties.
Might've gotten one in the two thousands though.
But we'll come back to that.
So that kind of a market is very much like the kind of market in the Jimmy
Stewart movie.
It's a wonderful life that gets created in his fantasy where,
you know,
the town gets taken over by the evil banker and that evil banker whose name I've
forgotten at the moment,
but that evil banker basically is creating the kind of loans almost that we're
talking about.
Now.
Everything's mechanized and standardized.
But of course with standardization you get tremendous advantages for one thing,
um,
these loans,
uh,
be I boy pulled together and being of the same general good quality.
They allow the lenders instead of lending to a bunch of homeowners and Peoria
like the bank would do.
Now all those Peoria loans are stuck with a bunch of other loans from all over
the country in the same big Fannie pool.
And so the lenders who are the shareholders have diversified their risk.
If the big businesses in Peoria,
Illinois go under,
it might be that all of the homeowners in Peoria will default on their
mortgages,
but not in the Fannie and Freddie pools because those are loans from all over
the country.
So you don't,
it would have to be that businesses all over the country went bad for those
loans all to go bad.
So secondly,
if you're getting a whole pool and there's an automatic criteria,
and for getting into the pool,
you don't have to worry that you're getting the worst loans or the cheesiest
loans or something,
you know,
the quality,
the general quality of all the loans.
And once you have shares in a pool,
um,
you can resell the shares.
So a bank who has to study the homeowner and,
and uh,
you know,
we have meetings with them and you know,
Jimmy Stewart had to look into his eyes.
So Jimmy Stewart may have convinced himself the guys a good risks,
but how could Jimmy Stewart ever sell the loan to somebody else?
The other buyer who hasn't looked into Martin's eyes,
he's never going to believe Jimmy Stewart that that's a good loan.
So Jimmy Stewart is going to be stuck with that loan for 30 years in the Fannie
and Freddie pools.
The shareholder who buys the loans and knows their standardized,
knows exactly the same thing as the next guy who might buy his shares from them.
So if the shareholder will be willing to pay more for the loan,
because he knows that if he needs cash,
he doesn't have to wait 30 years,
he can just sell his shares to somebody else.
So because of the diversification,
because of the reduction in adverse selection and because of this ability to
resell the shares,
lenders that has shareholders are willing to pay more for the mortgages.
And so the mortgage rate went down.
So I've estimated that this operation together with the next one I'm going to
talk about has reduced mortgage rates by at least a percent.
So if you think the average loan is 200,000,
you're talking about um,
you know,
$2,000 a year that the average home owner saved by this financial innovation.
So securitization seems to have been a great boon.
Now in 2002 when I made these slides,
I'll just give you an idea of the size of the,
of the mortgage market and you have to double all these numbers today pretty
much.
So you see that the know the stock market was around 15 trillion and the
mortgages were around 7 trillion at the time.
And you know,
that compares to 2 trillion for corporate bonds and uh,
or 3 trillion for treasuries.
You see how big the mortgage market was then and now it's twice as big as the
same size as the,
basically as the stock market,
which hasn't really grown since then.
So,
um,
you know many,
well,
I'm not going to talk,
but I don't have time to talk about this,
but of course of the mortgage market,
some of it is commercial,
some of it is residential.
The vast majority is residential,
but there's a very big commercial mortgage market.
I'm going to be talking mostly about the,
the,
uh,
the residential mortgage market.
Some of these mortgages are in fact held by the banks without selling them to
Fannie Mae or Freddie Mac.
But a lot of them are securitized just in the way we talked about.
And they're going to be private securitizations later that we'll talk about.
And so,
um,
now that securitized part is 10 trillion.
Um,
I'll give you the numbers,
uh,
recent numbers later.
So actually that maybe a little bit big,
the slight,
these 7 trillion,
the securitized part of the mortgage market.
So,
uh,
in 2002,
the,
uh,
agencies dominated the security market.
The securitized,
uh,
loans were almost all Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac.
There's also another agency called Ginnie Mae,
but there's another part of it.
There was another part of it,
which were jumbo loans.
So there was a size limit.
The loans couldn't be too small and couldn't be too big for these Fannie and
Freddie pools.
Uh,
we are trying to,
the government was trying to appeal to the middle class,
establish homeowner ship in the reliable middle class.
And so the wealthy were buying million dollar homes,
weren't able to get their loans sold into a Fannie or Freddie pool.
And so those loans were securitize the same way,
but by private agencies and not by,
by banks,
by investment banks and not by the government.
And that at the time in 2002 was half a trillion.
But we'll come to all these,
uh,
numbers,
later what he'd say.
Today's numbers.
So the next innovation after the 1970s came in the 80s,
and that's the collateralized mortgage obligation market.
CMOS,
they're called.
So the investment banks like kidder Peabody and Lehman Brothers,
um,
for example,
would buy some of these big pools and then they would cut the pools,
which were just pass through.
So the pools just pass through the money that the,
that the homeowners we're giving them.
So maybe they were passing through $1,000 a month.
It's the promise.
Well,
say kidder Peabody might buy a pool promising $1,000 a month to the shareholders
and then cut the promise into two pieces,
maybe a floater,
which would pay $500 plus the interest rate.
And uh,
so when the interest rate went up,
the payments would go up.
That's why it's called a floater.
And maybe a second piece called an inverse floater,
which is $500 minus the interest rate.
So as the interest rate went up,
the payments would get smaller,
but as the interest rate went down,
the payments would get bigger.
That's called an inverse floater.
So that way the to add up to a thousand dollars,
but now you can appeal to two different buyers.
A buyer who needs the money when interest rates go up,
would buy the floater.
A buyer who needs the money when interest rates go down,
would buy the inverse floater.
So by creating out of plain vanilla promise to more tailored promises,
you can target,
uh,
more sharply a clientele and therefore get probably more than half the money for
each of the two pieces.
And that way of course,
competition in the CML market raises the,
the amount people are willing to pay for the pass throughs because they can then
buy them and split them up and sell them for a big,
uh,
for more.
So that raises the price of the pass throughs,
which in turn raises the price of the mortgage.
The home owners can sell their mortgage,
which in turn lowers the interest rate that the homeowners have to pay.
So again,
it's another one,
another reason why this whole operation of securitization improved the welfare
of almost everybody.
So the pieces has gradually got more complicated.
So you know,
if there was default or somebody prepaid as we talked about and use their option
to pay early,
instead of getting the money you expected,
you'd get extra or less money than you expected.
And that created risk.
And some of these buyers didn't want to bear the risk.
So maybe you'd make the pieces 400 plus the interest rate and 400 minus the
interest rate and leave $200 to what might be called a residual piece or a
derivative or something.
And that $200 would bear the risk.
So if someone defaulted,
you take it out of the $200 a piece and not under the first two pieces.
So,
um,
that,
uh,
split up again made the float in inverse floaters safer and encourage people to
buy it.
But of course somebody had to buy the residual piece,
which was more complicated.
So as I said,
um,
this whole operation was a way of accomplishing two things.
It made homeowners able to sell their promises for more,
so they effectively were paying a lower interest rate.
So it made it easier to move into houses.
And that's precisely what the government intended.
By creating these agencies,
it also allowed buyers and investors to get money in the cases they needed it in
the states.
They needed it because the pieces were tailor made for them.
So I realized while I was there at kidder Peabody,
that this whole multi trillion dollar operation behind the scenes was,
as I said,
invisible to everybody and is worth writing about.
And uh,
it,
it was bringing a great welfare game to the country and,
and nobody quite knew about it.
So for me,
it crystallized what the essence of finances,
the essence of finances.
You're trying to create promises.
The financial system is creating promises that deliver money to people in
circumstances or states,
as I call it,
that they really need the money.
But of course you have to guarantee that the money is going to be paid to them.
So in order to do that,
you have to have collateral.
So this entire system is a way of creating promises and backing them with
collateral.
So if you remember,
so here are the potential promises and maybe some people want money down here.
That's when the interest rates go up.
They're buying the floaters way over there.
The money's going down,
the interest rates are going down.
That's the people who buy the inverse floaters.
That's when they're getting most of their money.
So,
but these promises you have a reason to expect to get paid because they're
backed by the collateral.
Okay.
So the is not a very good picture.
The houses back the promises of the homeowners,
like in Babylonian Times,
if the homeowner doesn't pay,
he loses his house.
Then the,
the,
those mortgages themselves,
those mortgage promises are backing the pools which are selling shares to the
shareholders.
But those shares are backing the Cmos,
which are making more complicated promises.
So the collateral you see is used once by the homes,
once by the pools,
once for the cmos.
And then it will turn out as,
we'll see a in a few minutes that the investors who buy our borrowing money and
buying on margin using the CMO piece is they buy as collateral for their
purchases.
So the collateral is being used and reused.
And so in fact,
the entire system is stretching the available collateral as much as possible.
So collaterals are very scarce resource.
It's very important to running a financial system.
Many developing countries don't have any collateral and therefore they have a
primitive financial system here.
There's a tremendous incentive to stretch the collateral as much as possible.
You can stretch it by using it over and over again or by letting the same
collateral back many promises.
And we saw both of those,
the trenching,
the different CMO pieces and the pyramiding,
the using the same collateral over and over again.
So,
um,
so I wrote my first paper,
published it in 1997 while I was,
uh,
I had written it while I was at kidder Peabody.
And one of the questions I asked was,
when you take out a loan,
not only what interest rate do you have to pay,
but how much collateral do you have to put up?
And that was a question that nobody seemed to have asked really before,
uh,
in a general equilibrium model.
And so I,
that was my first paper on the subject.
Now I want to get back to kidder Peabody.
Kitter Peabody's I said when I started,
it was a sleepy,
uh,
number seven ranked investment bank didn't dominate any market,
but it came to completely dominate the CMO market.
So this,
as I said,
was a multi trillion dollar market.
And if you look at all the pieces that are being promised here,
what Kitter decided to do was,
uh,
you know,
things got more and more complicated.
They weren't just two pieces that weren't just three pieces.
There were 90 pieces typically at that time.
And so a typical,
uh,
investment bank that wants sell,
you know,
buy a pool of Ansel,
the CMO pieces like let's say Solomon or First Boston,
they were the ones who first did these cmos,
they would try to line up 90 buyers and figure out what each of the 90 we're
willing to pay.
And then when they added up the prices,
each of the 90,
we're willing to pay,
they'd go and if they thought the,
some of those was bigger than the price of the pool,
they'd go to the pool and by the pool and then immediately make a profit by
selling off the 90 pieces.
Well it kid her,
um,
the head of mortgages who by this time,
by the way,
was my young little cousin who,
um,
through one,
well not accident after another,
but anyway,
through hard work had worked his way up to running the small a CMO operation.
He got the idea that would kill her could do was to find a buyer for the
riskiest piece.
The one that I've put in yellow,
remember the residual,
which was maybe called an inverse io.
It had different names,
but the riskiest pieces,
once he finally found a buyer or a place to put the riskiest piece,
he would borrow the money,
buy the pass through and hold an inventory of all the other pieces.
So he knew that eventually we would be able to sell off all the other pieces.
And so we had a tremendous advantage.
While everyone else was looking for buyers for 90 pieces,
we had to find a buyer for one piece or two pieces.
So we then had a,
uh,
an inventory of 88 pieces say to sell.
And as we did deal after deal,
that inventory,
we get bigger and bigger.
So are other,
salesforce would have a much easier time selling a piece.
We wouldn't have to call someone up and say,
do you want piece number four,
that's the one we're trying to get you to buy.
We'd call up and say we've got a huge stock of different kinds of pieces of all
kinds from all kinds of deals.
Maybe you're interested in one of them.
So it was much easier for a sales force to sell with that situation than it was
for the other investment banks to sell.
So of course we lured away some of the best sales people.
So,
um,
of course the downside to all of that is we had to be very careful that the
pieces we held,
we knew how to hedge.
We had to be very careful that when we held these pieces between the time he
held them and finally sold them,
we didn't lose a lot of money.
So we had to fix.
And sometimes we are the ones who held the most dangerous piece too.
So we had to figure out what we're going to be the cash flows of these pieces
and how to model them.
And that's what we're going to mathematically talk about the next few days.
But I'm going to give you a hint of this now.
So we had to predict,
among other things with the prepayments would be okay.
And so if you talk to a macro economist,
especially in those days and you say,
you know,
what do you think's going to happen in the world?
They'll usually say,
well I think in the next two quarters unemployment is going to go up half a
percent and then maybe things you're going to get better for the next year and
beyond that it's too hard to tell.
So these mortgages are 30 year mortgages.
You can't have a prediction that lasts a year and a half.
You have to have a 30 year prediction.
And the macro economist by the way,
are typically wrong even in their two months prediction or six months
prediction.
So how could we risk billions of dollars holding an instrument that's 30 years
long,
which depends on what people are going to do over the next 30 years.
Well,
the answer is you can't make a prediction and expect it to be right,
but you could make a conditional prediction.
You can say,
if interest rates do such and such for the next four years,
then prepaid and housing prices do such and such for the next four years,
then in that fifth year prepayments will be so and so.
That's a conditional prediction.
It's much easier to make a conditional prediction than an,
than an unconditional prediction.
It's shocking that so many economists are lured into making unconditional
predictions.
It's not a business we should be in.
We should always be making conditional predictions.
Well,
I learned that lesson at,
uh,
at kidder.
So you know,
the idea of possible worlds is going to play a central role in our chorus from
here on out.
And,
uh,
the possible worlds of the pads of interest rates are,
or our home prices.
And so you know,
here's a,
a very short,
this is maybe a one year into the future and we'd have to go 30 years into the
future.
So you can imagine,
and this is just uh,
actually much smaller group of possibilities than uh,
than we used to consider,
but you see all the possibilities that could unfold over the next 12 months.
And you see the Blue Line is one of those possible paths.
So we have to predict if we knew which path interest rates and housing prices
were going to take,
like that Blue Line,
could we then predict at the end of the Blue Line what prepayments would be?
Of course,
if the,
if you followed another path down to here,
we'd make a different prediction about prepayments.
So the cash flows or the,
or the prepayments and defaults that what was,
that's what we have to predict.
And so
you might say,
what good is it to predict a different number on each of these trees?
Then you just basically don't,
we are saying you don't know what's going to happen.
But that's far from the truth.
If you know what the payments are on each of the paths and then you can hedge
those paths.
So for example,
suppose the payments very low here and very high at the top.
Well,
if you can buy another instrument that pays you something at the bottom,
uh,
and,
and you pay at the top,
you can offset the variation and cash flows on the mortgage by that other
instrument and guarantee yourself the same safe payment all the way through.
But that's the sort of thing that we did at kidder Peabody,
which you're going to study in great detail.
We hold held these complicated pieces,
who's payments would vary tremendously.
So we ran a huge risk of losing all our money,
but then we would hedge them with some other instrument.
So in the end,
we've got a pretty safe return.
And because we knew the return was safe,
we felt we could pay a good amount of money for it,
whereas other buyers who couldn't hedge it wouldn't want to buy it at all.
So now let's just see how good the,
the,
the predictions were.
Here's a typical history of a prepayments.
So you can see it's,
it goes,
it ranges from to 99 from um,
88 something like that.
So it's a 10 years,
11 years of prepayments.
So that's the percentage of people who prepay every year.
So it's the analyzed percentage.
So every month you check how many people paid off their mortgage early and you
assume that rate stayed the same for the whole 12 months.
What would the prepayment percentage be?
That's what the number of measures all the time you see in someone's,
since practically zero,
these are prepayments for a mortgage issued in 1986 that had an 8% coupon.
So all basically 1986 mortgages with an 8% coupon issued by Fannie Mae or some
big pool of them anyway,
just to see,
sometimes the prepayments are very low,
sometimes they're incredibly high.
How standing at the bottom,
at the back there at an 88 say,
who'd you possibly have predicted that prepayment going forward?
You know,
with the ups and the downs and stuff like that.
Well you couldn't if he made it unconditional,
but if he made a conditional,
it's not so hard.
Cause,
what do you think happened in [inaudible] 93 that made prepayments go up so
high?
It was interest rates went down,
homeowners at an opportunity to refinance at a lower interest rate.
And we were in a different Morgan.
So of course they did that.
Um,
and and those other months when three payments are very low,
the interest rates were higher.
So,
um,
so clearly there's a connection between,
uh,
the mortgage rate you got and your original mortgage and the new rate that you
can refinance into.
And that is part of your conditional prediction.
But another thing that's interesting is,
is burnout.
So if you look at two pools,
both issued in one issued in 95 and one issue to 92.
And with exactly the same coupons,
you'll see that the older one is always prepaying less than the new one.
Okay.
At least starting from 95 onwards.
So it's as if the old one burns out.
Once it has an opportunity to prepay,
you see a lot of prepayments and then they slow down.
Okay.
So that's another thing people had observed.
So you might have thought the standard way of modeling things at that time was
to just do a regression.
You say,
well we figured out that prepayments depend on the new interest rate and how
much more in the money you are.
And it depends on how long you've been in the money because of the burnouts,
you try to estimate a curve,
like an s curve or something that depends on parameters.
That's you know,
on the interest rate and on the burnout,
how long you've been in the money and you know,
according to some parameters that describe the ass and you tried to estimate
those parameters.
So that would be an old fashioned way of measuring things.
But as we're going to see in this course,
we look at everything from an agent based approach.
So what are the individual agents doing?
So I,
so we got the idea or I got the idea of trying to model all you care about is
aggregate prepayments.
You know,
what does the whole cool doing?
But I decided let's try and predict every single homeowner.
So let's try and put ourselves in the mind of every homeowner in the country.
Why are they prepaying,
are not prepaying?
Well,
they're prepaying if they get an opportunity to save some money.
But you know,
we know from that graph that lots of people,
uh,
don't prepay even when there's a tremendous opportunity,
only 60% of the people are prepaying in a whole year.
So that means the whole year goes by and only 60% of them done have prepaid.
So every month,
you know,
eight or 10% are prepaying.
So the other 90% haven't seen their opportunity.
They've missed it or they've waited.
So clearly not everybody jumps at the opportunity.
So it must be that people are different somehow,
even though they have their own exactly the same circumstance in terms of
refinancing.
So,
um,
you have to account for the difference.
So I imagined that different people have different costs of prepaying.
It's,
it's a,
it's a hassle to prepay.
Maybe you literally have to pay some money to prepay.
Maybe you have to take a day off from your job.
Um,
some people have other things to do.
They're not that alert because they're paying attention to their kids or their
pay attention to their work.
So not everybody has the same alertness and everyone follows financial matters
as closely as everybody else does.
So also over time people are getting more rational.
They're beginning to understand the market and prepaying more and more.
And of course people hear from their friends if their friends are all prepaying,
it's more likely that they'll think about it and prepaid themselves.
So I,
so I will build a model.
I built a model together with the researchers at kidder Peabody and then later
we built a model of prepayments based on every individual making a different
decision.
So an individual is characterized by his cost and it's alertness.
So different individuals have different costs and different alertness.
And by watching how they behave,
we can come to guests what the cost and alertness is of each of these people.
So you see this model
captures all the effects that we talked about already.
If you have,
if you have a pool of people you can,
you can see the,
the,
the vertical is how many people of each type.
So there are different costs and different alertness.
And so at the beginning when you have a new pool,
like on the right,
there are a lot of people and as they get opportunities to refinance,
it's not random people who prepay.
It's the people with the highest alertness and the lowest costs who prepay.
So over time as the pool gets older,
the distribution of people is going to shift.
It's going to be have less hyper alert and low cost people and more high cost
and low alert people.
So that's why the pool is going to slow down.
So burnout is naturally explained by an agent based approach.
So anyway,
as we go through the course,
we're going to emphasize this agent based approach.
So building a model like that,
starting in the 1980s and making a conditional prediction,
you can get a fit that looks like this.
So notice you make some gruesome errors like over here.
That was an expensive,
uh,
98 97 98 that was an important mistake,
but you can fit this kind of prepayment surprisingly well.
Okay,
so that was the,
my kidder Peabody days.
And I thought,
you know,
my gosh,
we're doing incredibly well.
We're helping the country.
We're doing things on a colossal scale that nobody had ever done before.
I think I may have not emphasized enough.
They kidder Peabody came to dominate this market.
We controlled over 20% of all the issuance.
And remember there were trillions of dollars of things being issued.
So this little group of 20 year old kids basically plus me,
the old guy,
and we search.
So then the traders,
they were issuing something,
you know,
on the scale of half a trillion to $1 trillion of these cmos,
these,
these kids in their mid twenties or late twenties.
And I,
and the world seemed to be a better place for it.
And I thought,
my Gosh,
this is an untold story that needs telling and it's an incredible success story.
Well,
things suddenly changed.
And um,
in 1994,
there was a crash.
So this is the first of three crashes.
I've lived throat.
There was a scandal at kidder Peabody,
the Joe jet scandal,
who was a,
a trader,
a government bond trader who was accused of doctoring the books and faking his
big profits.
He'd been kidder Peabody man of the year in 1993.
And then in 1994,
he was,
um,
they decided that all his profits were fictitious and that he doctored the
books.
And so he was fired,
but he sued Kitter for discrimination.
And it was a tremendous controversy and was in the front pages of the papers for
months on end.
And finally,
uh,
General Electric who owned kidder Peabody,
closed the firm after 135 years,
or I guess 130 129 years,
they closed the firm.
So I had to go back one day to,
from Yale to Qrp body.
And I invited those 75 people and the research department into my office and I
said,
you're fired.
And then I got up and I went to the office next door and somebody said to me,
And so we all fire at each other.
And the entire,
130 year old company came to a close.
So,
um,
we,
the,
the head trader a of mortgages and bunch of his top lieutenants decided to form
a hedge fun instead of,
so kidder Peabody got closed.
I've actually sold,
it wasn't closed.
It was sold to Paine Webber and Paine Webber dropped the name kidder Peabody and
hired many of the people from kidder Peabody.
Um,
and in fact,
the second tier,
the more junior group of mortgage traders at kidder Peabody,
which was the leading mortgage company at the time,
they took over the desk at Paine Webber.
And then PaineWebber was bought by UBS and those same guys took over the desk at
UBS.
So the,
the junior crew at kidder Peabody ended up,
some of them were Yalies by the way,
ended up running the UVS are big part of the UBS mortgage desk.
But in any case,
um,
our mortgage trader,
they had guys and,
uh,
decided to form a hedge fund instead of selling though the,
the Cmos,
they would buy the cmos and we called it Ellington,
capital management.
So I was one of six partners.
I was a small partner cause again I stayed at Yale.
So this introduces the last player,
the hedge funds.
So what is a hedge fund?
You've heard the name I'm sure a thousand times.
It has a bad name now,
but I,
hedge fund basically means four things.
It means it's someone who hedges.
Okay.
You don't just buy and hold the thing and hope that the cashflows are good.
You try to protect yourself against as many risks as possible.
Just like I explained,
we were doing it Kitter when we tried to get the same cash flows in every
scenario and we're going to mathematically study that.
The remaining lectures,
but you're trying to hedge,
that's where the name comes from.
So you try and offset as many risks as he can.
Of course you still run some risks,
but your office setting as many as you can.
The second most important thing is most of it's done are a lot of the buying is
done.
Not Most,
but a lot of the buying is done with borrowed money.
That's called leverage.
So you don't just take your investor capital and buy some thing.
You take your investor capital,
you borrow some extra money,
and then you buy some stuff and the stuff you buy,
you use as collateral to guarantee that the lenders are gonna get their money
paid back.
So hedge funds generally leverage the third definition of a hedge fund.
Third characteristic is that they're very lightly regulated.
You have to be a sophist.
So what does that mean?
That means that a,
you know,
a broker who sells something has to make sure that the client he's selling to,
uh,
sorry,
the client on behalf of them,
he's buying the broker,
the stockbroker as to make sure that the,
that the purchased item is appropriate for his client.
We have no such obligations.
We can buy and sell.
Uh,
you know,
with anyone we choose on behalf of our,
of our clients.
But our clients have to be sophisticated investors.
So we have to vouch that they're sophisticated.
If they have enough money,
like say $5 million to invest in the hedge fund,
they're by definition sophisticated.
And then they don't,
the idea is they don't need to be protected by having a broker who's necessarily
watching out for there to see whether an investment is appropriate.
That doesn't mean that we,
uh,
we,
we tell them what we're investing in and we're,
you know,
of course we're obliged to explain our strategy,
but once they understand our strategy,
we don't have to check every single,
you know,
we don't have to meet the same tests that a simple broker meets on behalf of,
uh,
let's say a retired,
individual poor retired individuals.
So there's less regulation.
And the fourth characteristic is hedge funds typically charge higher fees.
So that's what a hedge fund is.
Now,
the first hedge fund was started in the 1940s,
I believe,
by someone named Jones.
And he was a stock picker.
And when he did is instead of picking,
let's say,
the best car company,
which he might've thought was Ford and leaving it at that,
he would try to hedges risk.
So he Ford and he'd short all the other car companies.
So effectively he wasn't just betting on Ford doing well because he could lose
if the whole economy went badly forward and every other car company would go
badly.
Instead,
he was betting that Ford would do better than the other car companies.
So he was concentrating as bet on something.
He understood more.
You can't be an expert about everything,
presumably was an expert about cars and he knew Ford was better than General
Motors.
So that was a Betty wanted to take,
but he didn't want to take a bat on the whole economy doing well or badly.
So that was the beginning of the idea of the,
the hedged a hedged fund.
Now there's so many risks that a car company or any company runs,
you know,
does their president know what he's doing?
Is Detroit going to be a good city?
Is there going to be a change in government regulation?
Is some foreign competitor going to appear on the scene?
Is the price of oil suddenly going to change?
There are so many things that can go wrong in a company.
It really is very hard to hedge.
So hedging really makes much more sense when you can make the problem
mathematical.
We'll see with mortgages,
it really is a mathematical problem to a much greater extent.
So it makes much more sense to hedge and I think it makes much more sense to be
a hedge fund if you're trading in the mortgage market.
And anyway,
that's what I found out when I visited Wall Street in those days.
So what did the hedge fund do instead of creating these cmos,
they hedge fund would buy them and of course by the most complicated one.
So in effect the hedge funds would buy the ones complicated.
Uh,
the,
the residual piece we're talking about and try to hedge that.
So effectively the hedge fund,
by hedging it was really carving up the cashflows of that last piece into
complicated ways and selling them off to stabilize its profits.
So it really,
the hedge fund actually was continuing the work of the Investment Bank of
creating more and more pieces and trying to allocate the risk.
And so the hedge fund is part of the entire operation,
which was making this,
um,
mortgage market behind the scenes.
Make home ownership so much easier and make people,
uh,
and reduce people's risks or so it seemed well,
mmm.
The hedge fund immediately started off,
we hit,
we had a hard time raising money to begin with cause after all,
um,
you know,
Peabody had just gone out of business.
So,
and not only have we gone out of business,
but you know,
there was a general crisis at the time,
it wasn't only the trading scandal of Joe jet,
but at the same time there was a crisis in the derivatives market because all
these complicated pieces that were being created,
we're money,
you know,
pieces went up and pieces went down.
Of course,
if you didn't know how to hedge your risks,
you could end up losing a lot of money.
So Orange County went bankrupt in 1994.
And what did Orange County do?
They bought a bunch of inverse floaters.
So when the interest rates were going down and the 90s,
they were making a huge amount of money.
And the,
the,
the fellow who ran a orange county's a municipal investments was,
was twice municipal investor of the year.
But in 1994,
when everything turned around and interest rates skyrocketed for the year,
his inverse floaters became almost worthless.
And he bankrupted our Orange County.
So we were the,
you know,
it was some of our inverse floaters that were being bought,
which helped bankrupt Orange County plus kidder Peabody had just gone out of
business because of Joe jet.
And,
uh,
so it was very difficult for our hedge fund to raise money.
Uh,
we almost had to,
uh,
our model was we created the mass,
let us clean it up.
And so we nonetheless,
we did raise some money.
We had an important a starting investment from the Ziff brothers and we had an
incredible boom time.
It made fantastic returns.
Our first few years,
50% returns,
and we grew into the biggest,
a hedge fund,
a mortgage hedge fund in the country.
And things were booming along.
And then suddenly there was another crash in 1998.
So this is the second crash that I was exposed to.
So what happened in this crash?
Well,
as I told you,
we were buying mortgages as they hedge fund buying that residual piece.
And buying it by with borrowed money.
So we would buy the piece,
you know,
let's say for a hundred by borrowing $80.
So we use $20 of investor capital,
we buy the other,
we borrow the other 80,
we buy the piece for a hundred,
and then we leave the piece with the lender as collateral.
So if we didn't pay them back to 80,
the guy could keep our piece.
So his hundred dollar piece was protecting his $80 loan.
So things was,
we're a swimming along.
We're going to talk a lot about leverage later.
Well,
in 1998,
our big,
uh,
one of the big competitors,
longterm capital,
which was founded as I think I've mentioned earlier in the course by,
uh,
Mary,
whether who was most important,
a famous,
uh,
fixed income trader on Wall Street from Solomon and two Nobel Prize winners who
I've mentioned many times.
And you're going to hear about again,
Merton and shoals and creators,
uh,
especially shoals of the black Sholes model.
The most important tool on Wall Street for managing risk is we'll discover in a
few lectures.
So these guys,
uh,
the three of them in nine other partners,
12 of them created this wildly successful hedge fund.
And in 1998,
it suddenly went out of business.
And in fact,
the government had to step in with all the big investment banks coordinating the
big investment banks to take it over so that the whole market wouldn't crash
down around it.
We celebrated the crash of a long term capital figuring that was one of our big
competitors out of business.
And now we would have an easier time.
But I remember thinking at the time that was a mistake.
But anyway,
a few months later we got a margin call.
So suddenly on a Friday morning in October of of 98,
somebody,
uh,
one of our lenders called us up and said,
we think the prices have gone down.
Uh,
it's not a 100 anymore.
It's less than that.
We need x million dollars of extra margin to put a free for us to contribute
because the hundred dollars piece protecting the $80 loan,
it was no longer a hundred dollars a piece.
It was a lower piece.
So there was less cushion.
We need extra cash to have a bigger cushion.
So we said,
oh,
this is crazy.
The prices haven't gone down that far.
That's not fair.
And they said,
you have till four o'clock Friday afternoon to pay us back.
And if you don't pay us back to him the next business day,
which happened to be Tuesday morning cause it was Columbus Day holiday on
Monday,
we'll just sell off all your pieces and pay ourselves back out of the proceeds,
the 80 and gives you whatever's leftover.
When we figured what was left over,
it wasn't going to be very much because they only needed,
they're 80.
So why they didn't have an incentive to sell for the best possible price.
Although of course they would tell us they'd sell for the best possible price.
They probably,
you know,
they wouldn't,
it would be a fire sale.
So we,
we,
we were,
uh,
we didn't know what to do and uh,
we couldn't raise the money by four o'clock on Friday.
So he called up Warren Buffet.
We said,
oh,
this is so unfair.
They're forcing us to sell.
There's no reason why we should have to sell the pre and all this margin call is
not proper.
It's not right.
It almost is,
you know.
[inaudible] there's no reason we have to sell.
I mean,
what's going to happen is on Tuesday we're going to force to sell all our bonds
at the same time.
And they're going all sell for like 80 or something.
Just give be a terrible bloodbath of firesale prices will go for,
nothing will be totally wiped out.
So unfairly.
Why don't you buy our firm,
we'll give you half are half are from,
you know,
some big percentage of our firm.
You just make the margin call for us and then you can have these,
this firm with these great bonds and you know,
there's the,
you know,
you can just,
it's such a travesty and it's going to be such a good investment for you and you
can save us and save the bonds and,
and stop this tragedy.
Travesty.
And,
and he said,
excuse me.
And we said,
well,
you know,
it's unfair.
We're going to,
they're going to force us to sell on Tuesday and the bonds will go for nothing.
And uh,
you know,
when they're perfectly valuable bonds and they're going to wipe us out and you
can prevent that from happening and own our great firm.
And he said,
hell,
I think I'll wait for Tuesday and buy the bonds myself.
And so Warren Buffet didn't rescue us.
And so that Tuesday it looked like we would go out of business,
but over the weekend we managed to,
uh,
hold an auction and sell the bonds ourselves.
So in other classes in economics,
you find out how to conduct auctions.
I don't have time to describe this in great detail,
but let me just say that in a typical auction you have to worry about the
winner's curse.
You know,
everybody's thinking,
I better not be the highest bidder because that means I've probably overpaid
cause he,
those are smart guys are bidding against me.
And so all our bitters,
so what we did over the weekend is we called everybody up and we said,
you know,
we've been forced by a margin call to sell these things.
There's going to be a great deal for you.
So why do you come back from your vacation?
One guy came back from Budapest,
one big trader on Wall Street.
We got a huge collection of traders there.
The weekend we showed them our bonds so they could think about that.
And on Monday we held our auction,
but he didn't sell everything at the same time.
At 12 o'clock we sold the first third of our bonds at two o'clock the second
third,
and at four o'clock the third third actually we got a little behind schedule.
But that was our plan.
And so what happened is that 12 o'clock everybody basically bid 80 so we said,
you know,
we're one of the bidders ourselves.
Of course we told everybody,
they all did it by email.
We emailed everybody back.
You've been outbid either by someone else or buy us.
You've been outbid.
So now these guys,
one from Budapest,
one are from all over the world back there thinking we're going out of business
bidding 80 they don't get to buy anything.
So what would they do?
What?
You know,
what are they,
what would they be thinking?
So between 12 and two were on the edge of our seats.
So they going to bid 80 again,
which means of course we get nothing cause we just pay back the loan for 80.
And we go out of business and our investors got a business or they going to
realize that they have to bid more in order to beat some,
you know,
other people.
So we had no idea it was going to happen.
But you know,
the price was basically 95 at two o'clock in 99 at four o'clock.
So we celebrated saving our firm.
And um,
it turned out there was another complication after that,
which I won't get into,
which is that the,
uh,
the thing had happened over the holidays.
And so the next morning,
um,
the buyers,
uh,
didn't get their bonds.
So remember we don't have the bonds to sell them.
They're sitting with the person who lent us the money.
So it was all a holiday and the bonds didn't get transferred to the buyers.
And so,
uh,
the prime broker was supposed to vouch for all of this,
you know,
it was a holiday for him too.
And so the whole thing was a mess.
And it's actually quite an amazing story,
which I don't have time to tell.
But anyway,
when the buyers didn't get their bonds the next morning on Tuesday,
they all got alarm that maybe we didn't even have the bonds.
And so everybody made a margin call against us and we went from celebrating to
suddenly thinking we're out of business again.
But sometimes when you're so badly off,
people realize that they have to stop.
And so there was a big conference call on Wednesday in which all our lenders,
the sort of number two people that all the big investment banks got together in
the conference call.
And the agreed that if they all tried to get their money back at the same time,
none of them would get it.
And so they waited for us to gradually work ourselves out of the predicament.
So we survived the crash of 1998.
And then after that we had another boom year,
an incredible year in 1999.
And things kept booming again for eight years or nine years until 2007 when
there was,
uh,
so before I get to that,
that experience was so seared in my mind.
The second crisis,
the 1998 crisis was oh,
seared in my mind that I wrote a paper called the leverage cycle in which I
said,
what basically happens is people borrow a lot of money and they're very
leveraged.
Then something bad happens in the economy and the lenders suddenly reduce the
leverage.
And so the big leverage buyers,
they go out of business,
the,
the leverage goes way down.
Lenders will ask for more collateral and there's also the bad news and those
three things together completely crushed the market.
And so lots of people are out of business and the whole thing's a mess.
But then after things settled down,
there's another boom.
So that's what I call and then it's going to repeat itself over and over again.
So that's the leverage cycle story.
I told in 2003 after I wrote it right after the crisis of [inaudible] 98 and I
said that this crisis,
which in 98 seems to be so small,
could repeat it on a much grander scale for the whole economy.
So in we had these boom years right after the crisis of [inaudible] 98 and then
in 2007,
eight there was another crash this time on a grand scale,
but it was exactly the same kind in the last two lectures of this course are
going to be about the most recent crisis.
And so we're going to mathematically reexamined this entire story.
So,
um,
and again,
after the 2008 crash,
when we almost went out of business again or a hedge fund in 2009,
we had the best year we've ever had,
better than all those other years,
even in,
in 95.
So we were,
um,
uh,
so three times in a row there's a crash,
a boom,
a crash of boom,
a crash,
and a boom.
We made back more money in 2009 then we'd lost in the crisis of 2007,
2008.
So the course has to end with an explanation of why these cycles happen over and
over again.
It can't be an accident.
I decided can't be all my fault that I've been in three of them.
There's gotta be something systematic going on.
And that's what I've been writing about and what our Howell and the course.
And by the way,
as you'll see,
I spent a lot of time talking to the Federal Reserve and Bernanki and summers
and also at the ECB in a,
the European Central Bank,
uh,
about the levered cycle,
which I think,
you know,
it's generally becoming recognized as a central problem.
But I want to end this lecture in the next 15 or so minutes,
20 minutes by pointing out one change in the market,
the next big change in the market,
the next wave of securitization.
Okay.
So this is the subprime market,
which we haven't mentioned yet and which I will now describe.
Um,
Okie and slide show from beginning.
Okay.
So what is the subprime mortgage market?
So we already,
I already pointed out the securitization was a great idea.
Okay,
now it was,
it was applied.
Remember to prime mortgages.
You had to be a very reliable homeowner to get one of those Fannie or Freddie
loans.
And because those people were so reliable,
although they didn't behave perfectly rationally,
you know,
they had cost and alertness issues,
they still were very predictable.
Well,
a combination of things happened in the late nineties is investors began to get
the idea,
you know,
this has worked out so well and there's so many people who don't own homes in
America because they're poor.
Maybe we can extend homeownership to still more people.
Of course they're going to be riskier because they're poor.
They have less resources,
but we'll charge them a higher interest rate and that will,
that will compensate us for the extra risk.
The government also saw this as a great opportunity to help the poor.
So this combination of investor's getting the idea and the government wanting to
sponsor it led to the creation of a new market,
the subprime market,
which is what I'm going to describe now.
And I'm going to talk about what went wrong or begin to talk about what went
wrong,
but I'm going to leave most of it for the last two classes.
So as I said,
securitization is so important because let me remind you,
typically when a bank makes a loan,
um,
the bank finds out a lot of people a lot about who it's lending too.
But you know,
the bank is not,
the bank has a bunch of managers and stuff.
The shareholders of the bank or the people whose money is at risk,
they aren't the ones looking at the loans.
So if you're a shareholder,
you own stock in a bank,
two years later,
the bank's going to make a loan to somebody risking your money and you've got no
idea who the guy is that he's the bank is lending to or what the characteristics
are.
The of the person who's getting alone.
Think of the securitization when you're buying a pool,
when you get this pool,
you could be told,
you know,
what are the characteristics of all the homeowners and the pool.
It's something very concrete.
A bank lends to homeowners that lends to businesses is doing 6,000 things.
Of course it's risky to have bank capital,
you know,
equity owned shares of the bank because you don't know what they're doing and
they're doing so many different things.
It's a lot you,
you should feel a lot more comfortable if where your money is going is very well
delineated.
And that's the idea of a securitization.
It's very
well defined where the money's going.
So it makes people more willing to land.
I mean,
you know the corporate debt,
that's another way of lending money.
But you know,
if you own bonds and affirm,
you know,
you're not the first person to get paid back.
The,
the,
the people lending with collateral get their money first and if the firm goes
bankrupt,
you know,
there's a big court case and it takes a long time to get your money back,
not in the securitization.
So there are many ways that a securitization is,
um,
more,
attractive than lending money through a bank.
And that's the reason for the securitization.
So now let here the current numbers,
the 2007 numbers and there haven't been much securitization since then.
So the agencies are now up to 4 trillion,
Fannie and Freddie.
Now those jumbo loans I told you about the big loans that the rich people take
out and remember,
which was point 5 trillion in 2003.
It's now point 8 trillion.
But there are two more markets that have been created.
There's the Altais,
those are people who don't have credit ratings good enough to get the Fannie
Freddie loans.
That's point 8 trillion.
And then,
but they're pretty good credit ratings.
And then the sub prime population of which there were Chilean loans issued by
2007.
So it's one point 8 trillion of lesser credit loans that didn't exist at all in
2002.
So,
uh,
you add these numbers up,
4.8 0.8 and one that's 6.6 and four Chilean of unsecured ties.
The banks are just holding the loans.
So over 10 trillion of loans,
as I said.
Okay.
And then you add the commercials on top of that and you're getting very close to
the value of the stock market.
So,
um,
all right,
so we've talked about this,
you know,
the advantages of a securitized loans.
You,
you know,
you,
okay,
so we've talked about all this.
So now,
um,
I went through that.
So,
all right.
Uh,
So how did the subprime market begin?
Well,
you had to have a few legal hurdles.
The first one,
which some countries haven't managed to,
to achieve and some people now are doubting we should have ever done is,
you know,
is it legal to charge a high interest rate to someone just because they're
riskier?
Is that usury or is that a reasonable return because you're making a bigger
risk.
So,
you know,
they're anti usury laws,
uh,
on the books.
And so in order to make these loans,
you had to get,
uh,
they had to become legalized.
You had to get Congress to pass a law to say that higher interest rate loans for
riskier people is not usury.
Okay.
So then you also had to figure out the tax treatment,
which happened in 1986 and so the first pools were created in the late eighties
early nineties and kidder Peabody,
by the way,
that firms I worked for a member at exactly that time was one of the first
creators of these subprime like loans.
So it was very small in the early days and it worked pretty well in the early
days.
And as I said,
by FY 2007 it had grown to 1,000,000,000,005 million people that an average loan
of $200,000 okay.
Now,
these are people who,
as I said,
I have bad credit ratings and so they pay a higher interest rate instead of say
6% at the time they might or 5% at the time,
they might pay five or 6% the mortgage rate at that time,
they might pay 8% for the first two years and then at the end of the first two
years the rate jumps up by another 3% maybe to live or plus 6% library remembers
the inner bank interest rate,
so it's already high and then it jumps up after a couple of years.
Now,
many people have said this is a kind of a predatory lending that the homeowners
being lured into taking out a loan,
not realizing that a couple of years the prey rate is going to go way up.
But actually there's some rationale to this is it turns out that if you've made
your payment for two or three consecutive years,
the market thinks you're not such a subprime person anymore after all,
many subprime borrowers are who are young.
They didn't pay their credit cards in college or they defaulted on something and
once they're married,
have a house,
have kids,
and they pay for three consecutive years.
The market figures,
while these people,
you know,
they're much better.
So we're,
we're going to get,
we'll give them another law.
They could refinance into a loan with a lower interest rate because they're no
longer considered subprime.
Maybe they move to all day or MEVV into prime.
So you could count on 70% by the end of the third year of people refinancing
their loan during all those years from the nineties and early two thousands so
you'd be left with 30% of the people who didn't refinance.
Why didn't they refinance?
Probably cause there there's something wrong with them.
And they were missing their loans.
They were much riskier than the original pool to begin with.
So naturally you're going to charge them a higher interest rate.
So it's not such a crazy thing that the interest rate went up after two years.
It does necessarily a sign of predatory lending.
Okay.
Now how do these loans get started?
Whether somebody called an originator?
Okay.
So a broker would find a homeowner,
a subprime homeowner,
and then go to an originator who would create the deal.
Okay.
Now what would the pool,
what would the deal be?
The Pool,
uh,
would,
be a bunch of sub prime homeowners and you'd have to get some data on the
people.
You don't have to figure out do they have a job,
what's their debt,
what's,
you know,
their income,
things like that.
And all that would have to be reported to the potential buyers.
So a buyer in the shares of these subprime pools,
we'd get a list,
not by name,
you can't reveal the name of the homeowners,
but what the zip code is of every house and what the basic qualifications were
of the homeowner.
You know,
do they have a job,
what's the loan to value on the loan,
what's their debt to income ratio,
stuff like that.
Okay.
Now,
um,
the servicer who is often the originator,
let's say the servicers,
an investment bank,
the originators and investment bank or the servicer might be the same investment
bank or a specialty servicer.
What they do is just with the,
the,
the banks did in the Fannie Freddie story,
they're the ones sending the letters,
telling people they have to pay,
collecting the money and dividing it up,
uh,
to,
to the bond holders while describe in a second.
And they are,
um,
they have one extra job because it's their subprime loans.
You can expect a bigger percentage of them to default.
And when people default,
you know,
sometimes they can't make the payments,
they lose their jobs,
something like that.
The servicers given the right to modify,
the loan servicer can say,
okay,
I understand you can't pay.
Of course you can't pay.
You're out of a job,
you don't have any money,
there's no point in us throwing you out of the house right away.
Maybe you'll get the job back.
So we'll work out a deal where we delay your payments or maybe we reduce the
payments.
Maybe even we reduced the principal that you owe.
Um,
cause in the end that's going to make our bond holders more money.
So the,
all the bond holders have no right to talk to the homeowner.
They don't know even know the homeowner's name,
but the servicer who sending the homeowner letters all the time and getting the
money,
of course the service or knows the name and has the right to modify the loan.
And if the homeowner doesn't pay and the Malones not modified cause the servicer
doesn't think it's worth it,
then the home,
the,
the servicer can kick the homeowner out of his house and take the house and sell
it and pay the proceeds to the fun.
But there's one extremely interesting a provision that if the is not pain during
the time the homeowner doesn't pay,
the servicer has to make the payments for the homeowner into the trust for the
bond holders that's supposed to give the in the service or an incentive to hurry
up and figure out what to do to change the loan or thrill the servicer that
throw the homeowner out.
And of course,
when the house is finally sold,
the servicer can recoup his advanced payments out of the proceeds of the sale.
And then later the rest of the money goes to the,
to the,
to the bond holders.
Okay.
So,
uh,
now the rating agencies played an important role in determining the ratings than
I'm about to describe.
So here's how the thing would look.
You'd have all the,
the homeowner's stuck into a pool,
all those loans.
Okay.
And then you'd,
uh,
I'm going to go for 10 more minutes.
By the way,
you have all these loans stuck in a,
in a pool.
So the money would be coming in.
The homeowner's,
remember a paying this high interest rate because they're subprime borrowers.
So there's $100 of loans that went out.
Let's say each loan is for a dollar.
Now the bar,
where does the originator get the money to lend to the homeowners?
Will the originators at the same time creating the bonds?
So there's be triple a bonds,
AA,
triple B,
you know,
with a bunch of minuses to the overcollateralization and the residual.
So you'd create $81 of triple a bonds.
These guys would pay that library bore,
you know,
the interbank rate,
which let's say it was 5% puts a tiny bit,
20 basis points.
So 5.2% the AA would pay a little bit more than that.
And the single AI a little bit more than that,
maybe that that's probably a misprint.
That should be library plus 10 library plus 20 library plus 30 and then the
triple B's live plus 130 so the issue $81 worth of triple A's,
seven of double A's,
five of A's,
five of triple B's,
that adds up to 88 93 98 okay,
so you're only getting $98 now.
So you've got $98 worth of bonds that you've issued.
So the originator has sold these bonds for $98 he's got a land,
$100 so he's $2 shorts so far.
But you notice that the interest rate,
all these bond holders are getting it's,
you know,
5% or a little bit more.
The homeowners are paying 8% so there's extra money coming in that doesn't have
to go to the bond holders.
So there's this residual piece that gets the right to get the extra interest
payments.
So the originator either holds the residual piece or find some hedge fund and
says,
okay,
you buy the residual piece,
and maybe the residual piece is worth five.
So 98 plus five is $103.
So the originators gotten $103 the broker's fees,
remember,
the broker had defined,
the homeowners get to,
so now he's only got $101.
So he lends the hundred and pockets one.
So the originator would get 1% bear,
no risk for his work in creating the deal.
Now,
how could these AAA pieces be rated AAA?
Okay.
Now,
to be rated AAA means,
you know,
there's a one in a hundred chance.
There's something that you're going to default.
So how could that possibly,
uh,
how could that possibly be when the loans are so risky?
Well,
what happens if somebody defaults?
Um,
okay,
so this is the calculation.
What happens if somebody's,
uh,
defaults?
Well,
if you haven't paid for the first 30 days,
um,
that happens quite often.
But if you go 60 days without paying,
nothing bad happens to you after 60 days.
You're,
you're,
you got a letter saying you're delinquent and the,
your,
you know,
a letters being sent to the,
to your credit,
a,
you know,
a note as being made that's going to have an impact on your credit score.
So being 60 days delinquent,
seriously delinquent is bad for the,
for the homeowner.
After 90 days,
you're considered likely to default.
And so you get these very threatening letters from the servicer and after 100
days,
the service,
you can start to try and throw you out of the house,
but to throw you out of the house,
maybe they have to go to court,
they have to do a whole bunch of things.
And so in those days it took 18 months,
14 more months after the four already to throw somebody out.
Okay.
And it now has taken,
on average a couple of years or three years,
it's getting more and more complicated to throw somebody out,
which we're going to get to in a minute.
So,
um,
uh,
so,
so anyway,
you can be thrown out after,
uh,
you know,
say 18 months.
Now,
what happens if you're thrown out of the house?
Let's say the house is sold for 80 cents.
Okay?
When you are,
when you originally had,
um,
a hundred,
a $1 loan,
well,
during the time the guy hasn't paid for that year and a half,
it was if it was an 8% coupon,
that means a year and a half is 12% so 12 cents the guy hasn't paid.
So the services had to pay up the 12 cents and then you have to hire a broker to
resell the house.
That costs six more sense.
And the guy probably didn't pay his taxes for the whole year and a half.
So that's another 3 cents or so that you've lost depending on what the tax rate
is.
So you've lost 12 cents of service or advances 6 cents to the broker.
That's 18 3 cents.
Uh,
for the,
uh,
taxes,
that's 21 cents.
And then the house only sold for 80 instead of 100.
That's 41 cents you've already lost.
So that's a sort of good scenario.
You've already lost 40%.
So the,
the,
the bond holders know that with this scenario they're going to lose 40% about of
their loan.
Now where does 40% is 40 cents.
Cause remember there's only $1 loan to that guy.
Where does that come out of?
Well there was this overcollateralization of $2.
Okay?
There's this extra money pouring into the deal because there everyone else
else's paying a higher coupon.
So you take the money out of the overcollateralization,
uh,
over out of this extra cash flow that's coming in.
And if the default,
the last 40 cents is more than the extra cashflow coming in that year,
then you reduce the overcollateralization.
You know,
there was $2 that um,
these bondholders rolling owed 98 and there's $100 of loans outstanding.
So you could lose $2 of loans and still have as much loans backing these bond
holders.
But once you get to the next dollar,
you're going to take the 40 cents first out of the triple bead piece.
Okay.
So as war and more houses go under you,
you,
you go through the overcollateralization,
the extra interest,
then you start taking things out of the triple bps.
After you wipe out that,
that wiped that out,
then you go to the aps,
then the AA and finally go to the AAA.
So how could you possibly think those pieces at the top?
We're a triple A's.
Well,
because let's,
let's do a simple calculation.
Actually,
they look incredibly safe when you start to think about it.
Um,
you know,
all this extra interest and the overcollateralization and stuff like that is
sort of 8% protection.
Okay.
And on top of that,
uh,
you've got the lower pieces bearing,
the original losses.
So,
um,
uh,
let's see where I,
okay,
so even if you expected a 40% of the homeowners to default,
which is an astronomical figure,
you know,
it was on,
it was typically in the past,
you know,
less than a few percent.
Even if you thought 40% of the homeowners are going to be thrown out of their
houses and 40% of each homeowner was going to be lost in the scenario we just
described a 40 cent loss,
40% times 40% is only six 16% but the AAA pieces are protected by 8% and then
they're protected by another 19% cause they're only the top 81.
So 16% doesn't come anywhere close to the AAA guys.
So that in 2007 was a horrible scenario to imagine that 40% of the homeowners,
you know,
there are 5 million homeowners,
that means 2 million people tossed under the streets,
losing 40% of each of the homes and you don't come close to touching the triple
A's.
That's why it seemed like they should be triple A's and why so many people were
willing to buy them.
Okay.
So one more,
uh,
I,
I got one more thing to add to this background piece.
The Cra,
the credit default swap.
And by the way,
things are even rosier than that.
Leaks looked at from the point of view of 2007 cause remember 70% of the people
were always prepaying.
That means you've got 70% of your money back for sure.
So you only had 30% of the people left who could possibly default.
And here,
you know,
so instead of having 40% default,
you probably have 40% of the 30% so you see there you could easily imagine that
your triple A's were completely safe.
Um,
and so I think the credit rating agencies didn't do such a horrible thing rating
these things as people say.
But I haven't finished the story.
So watch what happens.
So a new invention that happened in the end of 2005 was the credit default swap
cds.
They're called,
which you've heard a lot.
So what is a credit default swap?
So it's just insurance on each of these bonds.
So a credit default swap on the triple B would say if there's a dollar of
principal lost,
you know,
because the homeowner's default and you take the loss out of the triple B,
you can get insurance on the triple B.
This is a cds,
just is a promise to pay a dollar for every dollar that's lost in the triple B.
And the cvs on the AA is a promise to pay a dollar for every dollar that's lost
on the single way.
So,
um,
that was a huge market.
It suddenly took off in 2005.
Okay.
And then there was an index that was created in 2006.
So these are insurance on particular deals,
but if you put all the insurance together,
you can make an index of what the insurance is like.
And so you can tell how valuable the,
the,
the bonds are.
Because if you see that the insurance premium is changing,
you know that people realize there's a bigger default of a chance of default to
the triple B.
So the insurance market,
the index of it is going to tell you a lot of information about what happened to
the,
what's going on in the sub prime world.
Okay?
Now I don't have time to get to these legal issues,
but I want to add the last,
uh,
the last fact.
Things seem to be going so well in the subprime world.
You know,
from the late eighties,
early nineties,
all through 2000,
all through the middle,
two thousands that people got more ambitious still.
So what did they do?
They created CDOs.
So what our CDOS,
now
remember we had these loans that got cut up into bonds and there was insurance
in the bonds.
So people said,
let's take the triple B bonds.
Okay?
They're sort of at the bottom and they're protected a little bit,
but near the bottom.
And let's cut those up into different pieces.
Okay?
Tea.
So we take triple B bonds from all different deals.
We put those into another pool and now we cut those into different pieces.
Okay?
And so you might have the pool that's from California in a pool that's from
Detroit and a pool that's from Florida.
That would just be a horrible combination or a pool that's familiar,
and Illinois and Ohio and stuff like that.
And you put them all together.
And now the,
somehow the market decided that we could cut these into triple A's,
double A's and A's with the same logic as before.
Um,
but this turned out to be a catastrophic,
uh,
in fact,
the market went one step further and not only took the triple B's that we said
before and cut them,
made them collateral for more triple a bonds,
CTOs,
but then took the single A's from this,
which came from the triple B's and cut those up into more triple A's,
CDO,
squareds.
So that was the,
that was the mortgage market.
So the subprime mortgage market.
So you see that there's a tremendous amount of synthetic stuff.
Oh,
and by the way,
these insurance pieces,
if you're writing insurance,
you're promising to pay basically what the triple B's pay.
So it's like an artificial triple bs.
So they created a,
the synthetic triple B's and use those to cut up to in the CDO market.
Okay.
So I'm,
I'm,
I'm going to stop now,
uh,
with one final word.
So this sub subprime market of 1 trillion plus the all day market became the new
frontier of mortgages.
And as I said,
everything went swimmingly in the 1990s and the early two thousands and then in
2007 there was a tremendous crash.
So in January of 2007 February of 2007 the triple B insurance index plummeted
from 100 to 75 at that point,
everyone declared all this is just the subprime market.
It's a small thing,
don't worry about it.
Bernanki said there's no problem.
The stock market didn't blip it all.
It continued on until October of 2007 when it is high,
the world took notice of the subprime collapse,
but everybody said it wouldn't amount to anything because everybody
underestimated the importance of the mortgage market.
So we're going to see in the last two lectures how this unraveling of the
subprime market led to the unraveling of the entire economy.
And we're going to show that everything that I've described,
although it sounds very much more complicated with subprimes than it did with
the prime mortgages earlier,
is really when you get down to it,
the same story of leverage and crashes and then booms.
And,
uh,
we're going to begin the next class by talking about the mathematics of the
prime mortgage market and prepayments and how to value those.
And gradually we're going to get to the crisis and what caused it and what we
should do to prevent future crisis.
Thanks.